over the past 20 years the u.s has
borrowed more and more money as a
comparison to the share of gdp it's
around 100
the highest since world war ii the
biggest recent hike happened in 2020
when the coronavirus pandemic hit the
u.s and crippled the nation's economy
congress finally cleared a 900 billion
dollar coronavirus relief package just
before midnight last night and with it a
1.4 trillion dollar bill that funds the
government through the fiscal year the
question of whether it's economically
feasible to keep adding to this mountain
of debt has long vexed congress which is
in charge of the debt ceiling the law
that decides how much the u.s is allowed
to borrow we democrats supported
lifting the debt ceiling because it's
the responsible thing to do i implore
them one more time not to play russian
roulette with the american economy as
lawmakers prepare to likely raise the
ceiling again in early december here's a
look at how the us's debt works and why
economists say the u.s can keep on
borrowing at least to a point provided
of course congress raises the debt limit
there are some limitations though on how
much they can ultimately borrow and
those have to do with inflation and
interest rates
here's what happens when the government
needs to borrow more money to pay for
its economic agenda first congress
passes laws to determine spending and
taxes if the government spends so much
that spending exceeds taxes the treasury
must finance the deficit by borrowing
issuing treasury bonds and bills when
treasury issues a treasury bond or a
treasury bill this is basically an iou
an investor gives the treasury some
money an expectation that they'll get
the money back with interest greg ipp
who has covered the us economy for the
wall street journal for nearly two
decades says that people view treasury
bonds as a safe option for saving so
when the treasury sells bonds to
investors two things happen
first the government gets money to pay
its bills and second it agrees to pay
investors interest so when the
government issues debt they will use
that money to meet all the obligations
the federal government has they may use
it to send social security benefits
checks to recipients they may use it to
pay the salaries of the military or the
civilians in the federal civil service
and they may use it to pay the interest
on the debt they've borrowed in the past
if interest rates are zero then in
theory the government could borrow an
infinite amount because it will never
have to pay any interest on it
conversely if interest rates are
extremely high that really limits how
much the government can borrow because
the interest bill would be so large
today interest rates are at historic
lows which economists say means the
government can keep borrowing but the
treasury is competing for savers money
with other borrowers like households
companies and other governments if those
other people decide to borrow more the
treasury would have to offer a higher
interest rate to attract those savings
if interest rates go up a lot that's
going to significantly increase the bill
that the government pays for interest on
its debt in which case one of three
things has to happen either it has to
raise taxes to pay that added interest
it has to cut other types of spending
which nobody likes lord has to borrow
even more and then you get this with
this cycle where high interest forces
you to borrow more which raises the debt
which removes the interest rates even
higher and then you have to borrow even
more and that's a very dangerous cycle
to get into but there's another
limitation too if congress puts too much
of the borrowed money back into the
economy through things like stimulus
checks that can cause inflation if it
borrows that money and then goes and
spends it and that spending exceeds the
economy's ability to produce the goods
and services needed to satisfy that
spending the result is too much spending
chasing too few goods and you get
inflation and when inflation goes up
interest rates go up and you're back
into that problem of the high interest
bill making the debt unsupportable
inflation was 5.3 percent in the 12
months through august close to the
highest in 12 years but ipps says this
is largely a different type of inflation
this seems to reflect mostly temporary
factors we're coming out of this
pandemic so there's suddenly this surge
in demand and a lot of restraints on the
supply of a lot of products hopefully
these uh transitory shortages will go
away in a year too and inflation will
fall back
the kind of inflation you worry about is
when you have persistent levels of
spending that constantly exceed the
economy's fundamental capacity to supply
stuff that's the kind of inflation that
lasts for a long time
so
back to congress's role the debt ceiling
needs to be addressed
the only question is
who should address it and i hope our
friends on the other side will step up
and take care of it since 2011 each of
the seven times that the debt limit was
addressed congress did so on a
bipartisan basis congress decides on the
debt limit when the treasury has reached
it it can't issue more until congress
votes to raise the debt limit that's
even if congress already passed a budget
that requires borrowing this has led
some to wonder why can't we just print
off the money to pay the mountain of
debt if the fed prints too much money
this way you're back into that problem
of the treasury spending that money and
causing inflation and cause the interest
rates to go up with the option of
printing money off the table it will
ultimately come down to congress to
raise the debt limit in december to
avoid a default on the debt